uh we've got some breaking news uh  according to the wall street journal  that uh cineworld group the cinema uh  movie theater chain is preparing to file  for bankruptcies there's been reports in  recent weeks of the struggles they've  been facing the wall street journal is  now saying it's going to go as far as  having to file for bankruptcy cineworld  is of course  listed uh publicly listed in london and  the share prices have reacted negatively  to this news they're down 20  today and have been sharply lower in  recent weeks  anyway cineworld is in fact the second  biggest cinema operator  in the world some 9500  screens across 790 sites in 10 countries  uh of course the cineworld brand here  the picture house brand here in the uk  uh in the us regal uh cinemas uh is  their brand and uh down 21 percent the  share price today on these wall street  journal reports that cineworld  is considering filing for bankruptcy